All right guys, so now we are going to learn the ABC trading strategy
It's it's kind of similar to the New York session trading strategy, but more advanced and more profitable
It's gonna have huge rich reward trades. So
It's quite simple you want to identify a
Aviv which is
This so let me put this out. This is an a with
This is a beehive which is a small trend in the opposite direction or a pullback, right and
Then a fake out
Now what you want to identify is
When the a leg is complete
Okay, when the a leg is complete
And the B leg is complete
The sea leg
Must create some sort of structure
Which is this right?
It went up lower low lower high and then it went lower low
All right, I want the price to create some sort of low or a high
Before the sea leg takes out the a
Okay, so we got the a we got the B and we got the C. So what are the rules?
Identify a leg
Okay
wait
For be like to form which is a
Significant pull back
Or small trend in opposite direction
Let me put this like this, okay
Once we have the beehive then wait for
The sea leg to take out the low of the a leg
the low slash high if you're looking for a cell position, all right of the a leg
Then wait for the sea leg to take out the low or high of the a leg depending on what
position you're trying to want to trade in
the
Sea leg must create some structure
Before taking out the a
legs low high
Then wait for price to reclaim
the a level
Okay, wait for price to reclaim the a level and break that
Structure created in the sea leg
Then identify an order block
slash
Fair value gap and take your entry from there
target the
high
Slash low of the beehive
So this is a bit this looks like a bit complicated, but it's very easy guys, okay when I'm gonna explain it to you
so
What you want to do is identify a leg, which is a main trend so this big push to the downside is the
A leg right
Now
We have a small term trend in the opposite direction, okay, so this is the beehive
okay
And then this line right here, so let me disable this just to make it a bit clear, okay, so this is the
High of the beehive leg right me put this like this
High of the beehive which is going to be our potential take profit area, okay?
We got the a leg
Sorry guys, I
Made a mistake, so this is the a leg
This is the beehive, okay, so we got the a we got the beehive here
This is the high of the beehive and then we got the sea all right, so we got the sea
leg
Okay, so this is like the sea leg, okay, so within that sea leg
All right, we want to create some sort of structure
So as you can see this sea leg
Create this structure right before taking out the low of the beehive
right
Once that happens you want to identify a
market structure shift
Not below the beehive but you want to wait for price to break this level because it is
Above the beehive if the market structure happens structure shift happens here, then it doesn't count
All right, very simple
When that happens as you can see this was a structure within the beehive and the sea leg and
The price did not take out our take profit area
So this trade is now this setup is now valid
Okay, so we have market structure shift right here. Let me make it a bigger
Let's make it 24. Okay, so now what do we have?
Here we got the imbalance and the autoblock. So we are going to enter right off this level
We put our stop loss right below this level and we target the high
Of the beehive this would have been a three ratio what trade?
This is one of my favorite strategies actually my favorite strategy out of all that I'm teaching
But really depends on you. So
Let let me move everything here and let's
Re-vice what I've taught here. So we got the a leg. This is the a leg
The main trend trend leg. Okay, so we are in a downtrend. We see a push down and then we see a pullback very simple, right?
This pullback
This move is called V-leg. Okay, so it went
Boom, it's a beehive and we want to identify the high of that beehive which is this, right?
The high of the beehive must not exceed and I repeat must not exceed the a leg. Okay, it just must not break the
A leg level, which is this. Okay, so this is where the big push started if the beehive crosses this level then the trade setups becomes becomes invalid
so
We got the beehive and now we want to identify the low of the beehive which is this
Perfect. Now we wait for price to break
break through that beehive. Okay, and
The move that breaks the beehive is called
C-leg so A, B, C actually
Now when the price is about to break the beehive level
It must and I mean must create some structure
All right, so we got as you can see lower lower lower high lower lower high and then we broke
Okay, now below the beehive we also created some structure and I also break this level
But this doesn't count. Okay, we are only going to look for structure which is inside
The beehive and the C-leg. Okay, the lines that I've drawn
The the low of the beehive and the high of the C-leg there must be some structure before price takes out the beehive
Then we identify a market structure shift that happens then we identify an auto block
Which is right here and we take our entry. So this is
Three risk reward trade very easy guys. So now in the next video, I'll give you some examples. See you guys